hey everybody today we have our longtime
friend Luke's template in on the podcast
now Luke well we met him about eight
nine years ago
2009 he was working for machinima and he
was one of the first people that reached
out to us when we started YouTube and
actually basically started one of the
first multi-channel networks over there
at machinima it's crazy story since then
he's been he founding 3 black dot
working with the likes of syndicate
vanossgaming tons of awesome guys and he
knows YouTube inside and out in a way
that most people do not so right today
talking about creative ads and how to do
them yeah he it's basically the business
that affects our lives and affects yours
too as a viewer so let's get into it I
appreciate you taking the time to hop on
the podcast here because you are a very
interesting and intelligent person and
there's many things that you know that I
don't that I'd like to find out yes
welcome to the corridor Cass thank you
very much for being very excited to be a
part of the corridor cast I mean I you
know we've known each other for a really
long time yes I asked I was like yeah
but am i interesting enough for you guys
you guys are really interesting I think
the thing is is we we like use the
effects and costumes to make it seem
like we're like super green like we're
interesting but once those cameras stop
rolling you I'm just like I I'm a hermit
man I swear a little bit more harmony
right yeah but yeah
machinima right so yes just like we've
known each other since 2000
I think we met no 909 yeah it's been
yeah cuz like you guys like you were the
first like what how would I say it it's
when we're trying to turn our passion of
making YouTube videos into a business
you are the first person that really
like kind of reached out / made contact
/ like we the first the Fidel's that
first like real interaction with the
greater YouTube economy as a whole
because you were working with machinima
and it was we were just we were just
like holy crap we got noticed are you
guys well you guys made that great video
that you guys put up on Freddy's
frozen was rising yeah yep so yeah I
mean so if for those of you don't know
machinima is a still is very large
YouTube channel but it was one of the
original but Hemus along with maker and
and full screen and I was one of the
first 20 employees over there was 20
well yeah it was pretty crazy it was
really early days it was crazy and I was
sent to I mean my my first two weeks
there was the most surreal weeks ever
because like they just sat me down a
plastic fold-out desk hey you know I had
my own computer and they said no one's
gonna talk to you for two weeks here's a
list of our most popular videos ever you
need to give us a programming how you
would program differently different than
this type of content and find us the
next red versus blue that's all you need
to do and for those you don't know a red
versus blue is one of the most popular
and watched T watched internet pieces of
content ever that's still running today
it's crazy yeah so they gave me a small
task yeah and no one literally no one
spoke to me for two weeks and then we
sat on our first meeting and I got first
thing right off the bat I got made fun
of because I didn't have an active
gamertag yeah there's this 21 year old
intern there he's like hey what's your
gamertag ins like I don't have one
anymore and he's like are you [ __ ]
kidding me oh my god yeah I got started
getting hazed like right away that's the
culture though and okay well you know
what did you find in your two weeks of
research what did you find
and I said well you guys are only
programming like traditional machinima
and traditional machinimas like
puppeting like gaint using the game
engine you know which is an art form you
know there's any game engine to tell
stories and I think you guys should do
more gameplay stuff you know you guys
should do stuff like this kid named
hutch you know he's doing these
compilation videos and I had a whole
bunch of videos from him and you know
you've got X Cal hours but he only does
like a weekly top ten around like Halo
games like diversify get all these other
games and they're like and then I
secondly I said hey you guys should also
have content like this you know you
should have you know well with time
Freddie you know have you know video VFX
videos or you know game based well
yeah so I think technically you were
like some of the first people I ever
reached out to and I have a feeling we
were it's like I mean for lack of a
better word like after after that point
you know our relationship with like MC
ends um grew but like at first like that
was like a very like primitive yeah
structure working with you guys which
was kind of cool
it was definitely great for us for sure
as you know up-and-comers
but yeah fascinating well we we didn't
get to a deal right away with you guys
but we got to a deal with hutch and a
kid named blame truth who's still in the
community is still pretty active and
then seananners yeah and now both
seananners and hutch have taken off and
nanners and I are business partners
together and a couple my my so I'm a
co-founder of a company called three
black dot yeah nanners vanoss and
syndicate are all my business partners
and nanos and I like became friends back
in Ojai and same time we you and I met
and the video game community just took
off
like before that there was you know a
few hundred people if you will making
gameplay videos once machinima started
like monetizing it yeah yeah literally
hundreds of thousands of people were
submitting videos and it's like whoa so
I think in 2011 we were actually voted
Southern California startup of the year
Wow so it was really exciting like being
a part of machinima there's a bummer to
see it like crash and burn the way it
did it's still doing great and I really
wish nothing but the best for it but
it's you know it's it definitely didn't
reach what we thought it was going to
yeah well I mean for us you know us we
started as an independent YouTube
channel and that opportunity to work
well for us the decision to work with
machinima was really just the decision
to work with you because of the mutual
understanding and trust that was you
know involved with that but um at the
same time you know we're sitting there
in 2010 looking at machinima going hey
this is like the biggest YouTube channel
and they're like it's all all the stuff
that we're into as well so you know we
kind of wanted to be a part of that too
and see right ride that train and see
where it went
and I guess well we now know where that
train eventually kinda went right but it
was really interesting because at the
time everyone's trying to figure out
what YouTube's all about ashame is huge
we've it's it's it's trying to create a
model but that model doesn't didn't
necessarily pan out in the way people
thought it would and curious like what
what really is the cause of that or like
what what what MGM's were born out of
channels themselves not created
separately yeah yeah I can only speak to
Mishima and how it started it's MCN and
it's actually kind of a fun origin story
so I'm going to tell that story to do it
yeah and I'll ask guys likes Arkin and
nanos too backing up online if people
attack me but so what happened was like
right around same time again we met and
I remember we so we met in like November
or whatever I think of oh 9 yeah and we
were sword fighting out in you're out
yeah we're LARPing and talking about the
singularity yeah super fun and then
right around the same time what was
happening was nanners and and hutch and
all these videos were just absolutely
taking off so we were like hey let's
make its own channel
we'll make a Call of Duty destination
channel called respawn now I call it do
you a first-person shooter no
destination channel full respawn and I
remember the date perfect was December
17th 2009 it was a days the 17th is it
really yeah holy [ __ ]
check but the day respawn went live I
was sitting next to a guy named Mahmood
and mood is like one he's I love him
he's one of the coolest guys but he's
also persnickety and and really uh can
be really rude sometimes because it's so
blunt he's so blunt you're like whoa you
just said that out loud
most people doubt that back a little bit
he's wonderful
that way and I'm sitting next to him and
I might so my job was facing contact
graders guys like yourself guys like
manners all that stuff and talking to
them and and for a long time there there
she was back then was getting partnered
with YouTube you guys remember this
logback now yes so hard to be partnered
and it would take six months you'd have
to go through an application and then
they forget who you are and then
somebody else would come in and view you
and you'd be like start all over and it
was a nightmare
so that was my daily I was talking to
people about well you can only monetize
if you put it on machinima you know and
and we'll do what we can to help you get
partnered but we can't right now and
then on the day that respawn launch
we're all sitting there getting ready to
go live for the first time and I'm
sitting next to my mood and he goes
alright it's done
like what's done he goes I just finally
created the channel and it's up I'm like
what do you mean you just created the
channel I thought you'd created a while
ago he goes now I was waiting so how did
you do that like I'm so curious like how
you did that he's like oh it's really
easy through our CMS you know which is a
control management system that all
YouTube networks have you can just send
an invite to an email that already has a
YouTube account and partner with it and
it just becomes like a satellite channel
and I was like holy [ __ ] that's
incredibly powerful like why aren't we
doing this to the whole internet like
let's just go and get the whole Internet
to sign up through our CMS go around the
YouTube like system will vouch for the
channels will monetize it helps it
monetize the channels blah blah blah
he's like I guess that's I don't think
that's possible
why not so he literally stood up right
there and we walked into the executives
office and he was like can you you can't
do that it's like yay I can't he just
told me you good he's like moot can you
dance yeah he stood up and he walked
into the CEOs office was like 15 minutes
later he comes back he just leaves us
there sitting I'm like what's up he goes
do it like start with like five channels
and do it right now if you can really do
this if you can really do this this is
crazy so we've got respond it's our
first first like outs outside the
machinima proper channel going right at
the same time that we realize we can
start our network right so we
immediately start on the paperwork for
the network and you guys remember you
know I was back on mission when I got
blasted first time we I was like so we
had guaranteed CPMs but the kicker was
it was a in perpetuity deal yeah that's
like it was
first time reddit got word of us and
they hated us it felt like like pre
Great Depression kind of era kind of
stuff I think we'll give you this much
money for I know but but but seriously
that spark though that spark of that
realization of what you could create
like you mean that that's like literally
the origin of the MCN right there right
it's crazy
yeah well hadn't you and then we
immediately started game channels and
then I immediately said hey I don't want
to do like I love gaming all of the
channels but yeah I want to work with I
mean you guys were one of the first
channels I signed
wreckless Tortuga I mean roosterteeth
obviously but dad they're on CMS but
they were rolled under ours
so I managed them I managed FPSRussia
like all these you know entertainment
channels which were gaming themed but or
had some gaming tangential but were more
entertainment you will
yeah and that's how the NCN started gun
and how it rats really would or made
dick jokes are that yeah yeah and that's
how I mean that's how the MC had started
for machinima I was like there day one I
was like that's crazy easy how's that
possible
YouTube really lets us happen right
there and but that's the thing it's so
easy that that's how I guess you get to
thousands and thousands of channels and
stuff and then I guess kind of
effectively the blowback of of the whole
concept in general which is you know
can't really give a service unless
you've yelled out a huge service team
mm-hmm you know customer service team
and a management team
you really can't serve thousands of
people like I mean I when I left I think
they had something like 65 thousand
channels good and they had like eight
people managing that odd possible the
possible yeah yeah yeah that's that's
crazy so um you know like one thing
we're you know we were talking about
there then is you know well I guess CPM
is that's kind of like the that's that's
like the root economy of all YouTube
professionals yeah you know it's like
what's your CPM yeah how is your ad
rates you know does that supported
content and so you know
in general that's how so CPM for those
of you out there hello internets its
cost per mil or custom and well whatever
it's causing yeah cost per thousand yes
think of it that way so for every
thousand views you get X you know and if
you have ten thousand views that's x
times ten you know pretty simple and
that goes across all the internet you
know CPM is on medium or whatever it or
that's the term they use and back then
CPM is really varied mm-hmm and what me
I'm gonna tried to do is come in and say
we're gonna do a flat rate CPM yeah cuz
we're like a Google preferred customer
what David before Google preferred but
we're we're selling our CPM pretty high
and you guys are getting like a dollar
20 we'll give you 250 per CPM and then
we'll keep whatever's on top no I mean
people had done CPMs online before but
that was the first time where it became
proliferated especially in video yeah it
was never I mean there was podcasters
who had it there were other sites that
had it but those were all working in
entirely different industry this
basically processed bird of video
monetization well not this process I
mean I I would start so I I think the
most so I had a lot of cliches like
woody calm cuz I'm kind of in sales you
know because so I do brand sales I do
YouTube management I do a lot of
different things you know you have a lot
of snippets that are reused yeah
analogies
analogies I'd say the most of them is
one of the most important moments of the
past hundred years period any
corporations made any decision they made
the single most important decision I'd
put it in the top five is it's Google
saying in 2006 we're gonna start a
partnership program does it enabled this
whole economy we're talking about yeah
right if they don't cuz ad sales prior
to that right went through the
distributor right and the distributor
held the keys this should be of movies
should be TV disturbia radio newspapers
every Honda they you know and that was a
small group of people if you're looking
back 50 years ago 25 years ago you're
really looking I had a really small
group of people who owned all the ad
inventory in the world
mm-hm you know and I mean yeah small
group of 2530 companies right you know
conglomerate said on TV stations
if I come time-warner and then YouTube
all of a sudden is like why we shouldn't
advise video makers to make more videos
we'll just share a part of the CPM with
them holy [ __ ] I mean I hope my business
is built on it your business built on it
and you know we're part of that
evolution of like ad tech that's like
democratizing if you will the Internet
sure it's weird
well I mean I can I can imagine a few
ways why that was very profound and
important but how would you like explain
that well it could incentivize content
creators to post their content here you
know and and on YouTube yeah and then
incentivized a very young I mean when I
met you guys
oh yes 23 yeah round they're like 24 25
same thing
I met Clint when he was 17 or 18 yeah
right you know I mean I met all I mean
Tom syndicate was 17 I mean all these
young content creators that are now huge
and you know make their living off of it
you know you guys are young content
writers who are hungry and wanted to get
your [ __ ] seen yeah
YouTube is best platforms are that and
it was the only platforms like enabling
you don't monetize well I'm saying like
come here to like the the I guess the
concept of the ad world as a whole hmm
like how does that make that significant
because it's just it's video it's not
like video is the source of all media
and like Google ran ads on plenty of
things yeah before YouTube videos right
like sir then they have they had search
ads etc oh yeah if you look at what
Google acquires the number one thing
Google acquires is ad tech yeah I mean
there they are effectively in
advertising I understand the artists are
not effectively they are an advertising
company they did 68 68 billion mm-hmm 68
in gross sales in gross sales last year
they are an ad tech company oh yeah
they're search you know them for search
and all that stuff but 68 billion speaks
words oh yeah I was on a paint my first
panel ever whatís it was owned i/o 2010
or 2011 and he was a to filter panel and
we were sitting around I'm trying to
remember who was on the panel but we
were kicking around like what the term
was people were using because back then
we used producers and whatever now and
then and somebody was like and then I
also hate that term influencer and I was
like yeah but that's the one that's got
a stick yeah I was like I don't know why
I just felt like it was the only one I
was sticking because like when you say
producer it's too nebulous or no
whatever all this different stuff and
then we got into this argument of what
an influencer was yeah and now that's
the term that people are using and it's
an awful term like it's so vague mind
yeah it's it's it's you it sticks
because it's ultimately true and I think
you know we yes it's it's it's what you
call someone working with an
ad-supported
system in a way it's like you're you
welcome to be add support it don't have
to be add support anymore I guess so but
the only way that they can make a living
on the best way they can make a living
up being is ads I mean what this what
that did alright so you know if you if
you look at the influencer economy being
built off that decision and contact
critters like yourselves and you know
the peopie is the world and the vanoss
is there were all these different huge
content creators popped up with you know
what that creator was a different Avenue
for advertisers to buy and up until 2016
you know which is just two years ago and
then our my mind you know super late but
the 50% of 51% of advertising up until
that moment was spent in traditional
advertising yeah which makes no sense
yeah I mean who watches a real one the
last time you watched a commercial yeah
your parents do I guess but even my
parents can skip mercial now 2016 yeah
curious 2016 is that just the turning
point or do you was there an event that
pushed that I'm not sure familiar with
like the chart there yeah I know where
is that was the year that was the first
year in which digital advertising
digital ad sales now paste traditional
okay and just be the growth basically
the growth yeah okay not like not like
oh okay cool
no it had been trending it had been in
training like it's out of a can
I mean I want to say by 2011 2012 it's
only like 30 percent of the add it group
really quickly yeah I mean I guess in
the turret scope of like the entire ad
industry going back to the 1800s like it
would be a cannon shot it's a cannon
shot it's really fast and now it'll be
interesting to see where it's out now I
imagine
well about 55% so now it's really
eclipsing the the smaller well I mean
it's you know why why would you do
anything else like everything else is
just like throwing fliers out into the
wind basically there you know there's a
two hundred billion dollar industry out
there that's that's no I know each other
over that no they're like okay so on
this part of downtown this is where the
democrat be like the bankers neoprene
fliers green flies yeah they like green
yeah I know there I know there is that
industry surrounding it but it compared
to the laser focus of like having a drop
down then you have exactly who you're
trying to advertise to again you and I
totally are we're on the sentence the
problem is we're having a discussion
where we're both on the same page it
makes no I makes little to no sense in
my mind to do traditional advertising
unless you're really unless you have so
much money like you know I'm a coca-cola
and I'm a Pepsi or a Toyota right where
I can spend a good chunk on digital and
I can blanket the traditional
advertising so that I'm really just kind
of making sure that I'm hitting you at
least three times hitting the older demo
mmm-hmm you know the people actually sit
through the commercial still you know
and and all that stuff because they're
younger demo for the most part either
have ad blockers on or like we you know
I I mean most of the business we've done
sadly and I mean sadly I'm very proud of
it right but most of the business you
and I've done quarter and three BD and
and Luke have done with you guys is his
branded integrations Yeah right because
that's the value I can bring to you yeah
I can't add block those you can't add
block them but also it's it's a more
authentic way of evaporite yeah and
that's where you know we're at right now
that's where that's where it's gonna I
think will be the next change but we'll
see yeah well I mean I think we can we
can weigh the pros and cons of that
shift you know that targeted shift you
know I feel like you can you can
definitely look at it as a con if you
imagine yourself in the middle of like a
million laser sighted crosshairs of all
these targeted ads trying to like figure
out your patterns and routines but at
the same time it just got a little
thought here yeah let's say you live in
a world where that fifty five percent
number online and digital ads turns into
maybe like an 80 90 percent or something
like that I'm Jason I happen I'm just
imagining going for like a drive or
something like that and not seeing as
many billboards and like how much like
less advertising you might or or or
maybe maybe it's just it's like it's a
dream but I mean what if but every
screen every screen can be a billboard
though saying yeah face tracking right
and yeah dragging no I mean if you get
you know it's funny with two things
yeah we won't talk about the 55 percent
real quick I do want to come back to it
yeah so 55 Internet you're gonna crack
me and you're gonna give me you know
it's fifty three point four percent this
year whatever I'm just giving generals
this 2016 where it you know eclipse 50
percent blah blah I think it'll get 55
in the next couple years and then you
know hopefully to your point to 80
percent that's where people I cure self
make a little bit more money cuz you
know I see what you guys are doing it's
incredibly impressive and it's still a
real hard business to build and we can
talk about that when it's ad support but
of that 55 percent right two companies
sell eighty percent of that Google
Google Facebook and Facebook right
Instagram Facebook Google and YouTube
it's crazy now that's where the paradigm
is really shifting mmm-hmm I really
really shifting and it's a weird shift
cuz like anyway everyone's coming down
on Facebook because of openness and
fairness and all this stuff and they're
kind of missing the point I mean in a
way not missing the point and they're
there nothing's gonna probably change
out of this I mean Facebook will act
differently and they'll be nicer and
they'll make sure to block certain toxic
and they'll be following all these
people but at the end of the day they're
making billions of billions of dollars
and they're employing a ton of people
and they're changing the ad world what
are you gonna do to change it the only
way to change those habits and that
shit's not happen anytime soon
mmm-hmm yeah I mean so you the
difference in the world we used to be
aware as of 2530 companies running ad
space now you're literally doing it
duopoly and the question is is that a
good thing
okay and what can you do to change it I
mean I
have ideas and thoughts but it's it's a
it it's gonna be really fascinating
because when when you get to 80% you
know cuz look at what they're doing yeah
I can't imagine getting to 80% on our
current trajectory without like
maintaining the duopoly oh no you can't
yeah I don't see how you changed it
duopoly
I I mean I do but it takes a real effort
on everyone's it's gonna take it Bri
left yeah and something super like crazy
and sticky no but you know it's a great
movie
what cuz we talk about movies a lot yeah
my neighbor to report I know yeah and
was last time watch that a while ago but
I I can remember every part of it
perfectly it's really it stands up yeah
it's a good film it's a fantastic film I
think on I watched it I didn't love it
that much I remember just doing yeah
whatever
I watch it recently it's [ __ ] it she's
my anguish it's really good
it's super good is a good film and it's
some great action sequences but the
advertising that's in that mm-hmm that's
where we're headed bro dude where he
walks through the mall and he's gotta
like hide himself because everything's
recognize him and like oh yeah dude
that's where we're headed because look
at what they're both investing in yeah
right you know yeah magically mm-hmm
which is the largest startup I think I
actually might be wrong about this my
internet looked me up on this one
it I think it's raised the most capital
for a startup what does magically do
again get there in one second by far cuz
I believe they've raised 1.3 billion
dollars as a start-up and they haven't
come out with a product yet what the
[ __ ] so magically those interactive they
are okay what I'm trying to get at is
look at what these companies are
investing it right I mean you want to
see their future yeah look at what
they're putting their capital yeah
Google I believe is invested 500 or 600
million of that 1.3 billion won I just
can't even imagine not having having
raised money as a start-up yeah and how
hard that is
and then to think wow these people
raised 1.3 billion dollars yeah like
raising 2 million dollars on an idea is
real
yeah it's amazing that they've done this
and I the fact that they might still
have a product it's unbelievable we all
I when they first raised it the first
raise they did their first raise at 300
million it was like government great
investment what do you think they're
gonna try something magic wait just like
my new report exec with him say they
want to get it into real life do you
want to get your yeah they want they're
gonna they're gonna create a platform or
an experience right where you know
you're interacting with the ad you're
interacting with the content right there
the write down in there
I that would be my gut again I have no
idea I'm not seeing the technology
anything you can find online is is what
I've seen when I read this funny news
story um apparently uh um in order to
catch or identify some of Taylor Swift's
stalkers they a nurse they installed a a
kiosk yeah with facial recognition
software at one of her concerts and it
was basically all it was was like a
video screen playing some like
behind-the-scenes footage of my herd
doing stuff or whatever getting ready
for a performance but there was like a
camera installed there yeah and each
time someone walk up and start watching
it would basically try and identify that
person I I don't know they didn't say
whether they caught anyone or whatever
but they've started doing that to
identify people so I guess yeah watch
out if something is your attention it
might be recording you too well yeah the
social meet the real IRL social media
score it's so stupid
I mean China will mess it up but they'll
get it right in the future I mean you
know what I mean there's a great clip
being shared online I've Bill Clinton
mm-hmm he was president saying well
we're not gonna be like the Chinese you
know we're not gonna try to control the
internet because you can't do that you
know you can't control the internet yeah
you know you fast-forward to now and
right well they did a pretty good job of
that yeah hey they got done right bill
well no well I'd say they didn't I'd say
they got it wrong but in their eyes they
you know they feel like they got it
right but and then you look at Facebook
sorry back to what we were talking about
you know the duopoly we've got
Facebook's investing in you know they're
investing in VR technology and AR
technology you know to create that
you know for lack of a better word
create the oasis right and said this do
you want to get into this now with the
whole like like integrity and in content
and like what are you talking about
because this this brings this brings up
the thing that I wanted to bridge as
part of this which is like in the
traditional ad agency world you had 25
companies that were controlling all the
distribution of all content who were
communicating directly with the
government who were communicating on a
level of like we got to make sure that
we're looking at through these people
and we're looking after these people
were keeping eyes on the Communists and
we're keeping eyes on this and that
right now 25 years later that's all gone
and now you haven't gone not gone but
it's not completely separate it's it's
completely changed and what you have now
is yeah you have the ability to to to
and basically this is at least there's
real information coming out today that
that this is basically what the Russians
did and the in the last election they
use the system against us yeah they used
it to create actual discord within the
United States and they did it through
the use of our social media there is
real reports on this no it's for sure
it's very real who's so integrity I mean
I guess when I think of integrity I
think of contact craters like you guys I
mean we're talking about two different
things right the integrity of the system
itself well yeah I don't know if any
creator I don't know how much you can
speak to that I mean particularly if you
look at like how the viewership has
fluctuated just this year based on
algorithms right like you guys haven't
had any control over that know yet your
viewership went probably like this yeah
day went up and down no really weird
yeah and YouTube's not been transparent
completely with what happened there but
something happened right they changed
something you know and and well yeah
what it was we don't know they didn't a
lot of subs people you know I can't I
can I speak with them directly I'm and
I'm not bagging YouTube I think they do
a great job what they do
yeah and it imagine having 1.6 billion
you've got to serve you know and you got
to do it well that's the hot thing is
you dramatize how bad YouTube is at
their job but then you you
as the platform they're doing a rebel
job is really impossible it's impossible
Facebook not so much well I'm just
saying like I I'm just I think it's if
you want to bring up that subject if
there's like so many things happening
within it right that like you could
poopoo on and I think it's tough to
single out I guess one of them as like
necessarily the the issue here because I
think what you're when you bring up
integrity
there's a couple things you're dealing
with you're dealing with integrity of
users first off yeah um so you know
naturally you're gonna have some people
out there who are trying to hurt
malicious or malicious users to speak so
you inevitably have that crowd so you
can cater you know malicious users mess
with the system or try and take
advantage of it or you can just you know
anonymously you know having a laugh at
someone else's expense so you have that
yeah you have the fact that the system
itself is effectively AI based and not
controlled by people as much as people
expect it to like I remember I mean you
couldn't possibly like do what YouTube
does and have it not right I mean to
ingest millions of hours of content and
deliver billions of hours of content
especially with Facebook's okay this is
once again I'm not gonna verify this but
I'm pretty sure that I saw this thing
about how at one point in time
Facebook's AI generated a targeted user
base called quote-unquote Jew haters as
a potential audience to advertise do and
other categories or something like a
fake news I'm you know I'll take a look
but it's one of those things that like
ovate me it's you you have these eight
okay I mean I was good I'm not saying
this in full confidence but I'm talking
about a system that generates answers
and tries to create categories outside
of human control and so you have these
systems that are like you have to eat
you have this potential for like a
system to go oh this is a class of
people and when and you have the actual
users like whoa
hey I like Batman robot yeah you know it
was not advertised like you know but I
mean regardless if that's if that's the
the actual categories created like you
do have people who can still access
categories of your similar like
demographics to advertised to I don't
worry you're sayings incredibly poignant
I think it's really hard to communicate
to you know their regular listener
exactly what you're saying
mm-hmm but okay I see both YouTube and
Facebook being incredibly powerful
systems
yeah and ecosystems both of which
attempt to do a great job the difference
for me back to the content creators is
YouTube's actively created a content
creator program right now the content
creator can make money
we're on Facebook for whatever reason
literally I've been talking to them for
three years for whatever reason they
refuse to do it yeah right because they
don't want to share their money and they
don't want to you know they you know we
want to create a system that's more like
traditional whatever you want to call it
that's true no way okay so yes but see
this is what I'm talking about it's like
[Laughter]
you're you're confirming that the AI of
Facebook algorithm created created a
subset or a I guess we called head of
humanity a demographic create a metadata
tag a tag it's basically the create an
entity created a metadata tag that said
you hit her no way are you confirming
this brain now either that so if you I
mean I just want to play okay so yeah
I've done this because we we are going
to be releasing a thing next year which
we will we be using Instagram and
Facebook marketing for and so yeah going
through the system you you get a really
comprehensive list of people to market
to I can I can find a category of
Dungeons and Dragons fans on Facebook oh
for sure it's that D&D I mean I
understand I'm just saying but you can
you can get down to those my new details
and it's seen get dungeon dragon mage
I'm in the age of 25 and 35 I want to do
players who only play Ranger probably
could
ya know but it's it's it's incredible
like the the level of targeting it's so
cheap - it's crazy
well it's cheap and that's what's and
that's where I mean listen that's where
things are need to either change or
evolve this is this is where I think we
I just want to say I think the reason
why it's it's gotten so crazy with with
what you're saying here Sam is because
we are almost victims of our own
privilege in in in in the in the in like
the first world having access to free
information all the time that's supposed
to be fact checked and curated and like
accurate leaves people to read something
and go oh [ __ ] that's true even though
it might not be because somebody else on
the other side is manipulating the AI to
give you that information it's just this
was like unprecedented that that's
dealing with that I don't know how we
deal with that this all goes back to
advertising and marketing sizing and
marketing so it is one of my favorite
stories is the De Beers story okay and
diamonds and diamonds yeah so De Beers
is a wealthy family that owns something
like 85 90 percent of the diamond supply
in the world and they got together with
Tiffany's or Cartier or camera which was
in like the mid 30s okay I don't know
date fact like check me on that okay but
they basically said hey how do we
convince people that you know you must
have a diamond everyone needs diamond
and they they actually still have some
of the storyboards of the things that
failed all right and they're kind of
comic anyway well they were gonna do
that and then they land on everyone
needs an engagement ring right you know
me every couple concept did you exist
before that well it would it consisted
but in their way and they just took an
old idea a dowry or uh or some sort of a
get you know gift that happened at
wedding and they flipped it on its head
and said no this needs to come from the
man to the woman and she'll love you
forever cuz diamonds are forever and
that moment I mean you think about that
and then you think oh wow diamonds must
be super rare no there's a
for everyone in the world to have to
like that's that's how not where they
are it's just one one family just holds
back the floodgates Lisa's a little bit
every year it's not like it's a and it's
not I'm what I'm saying is I'm not only
not untrue not unknown
yeah there's a story yeah yeah so what
we're talking about is is how you how do
you manipulate people you manipulate
people with really good marketing and
that's what Russia did right hey
manipulated all of America one way or
the other
myself you you guys everyone right by
through strong marketing tools yeah
tools created by the ecosystem where we
should where we share and and and look
at content mm-hmm right [ __ ] great
that is [ __ ] crazy
yeah so what I want to go get a diamond
right now I want a diamond and I want to
know what like what do we do from here
what do we do oh boy yeah yeah I mean I
think it needs to be it's on the user
and it's on the community to create the
solution yeah right it's just it's a
tough one yeah you know cuz I got into
this with my brother and you know we're
literally not talking about people get
weird when money's involved yeah you
know and like let's just say
hypothetically yeah we'd sign a contract
right now just like we've done before
between the two of us where you give me
10% of everything you make and I'll do
XY and Z for you mm-hmm that's it that's
a big contract to sign you know I mean
and we're best with just a little bit of
money right now imagine if everyone in
America said hey you know what we want
to sign the same contract right and we
want to you know take a 10% away from
Facebook and YouTube what would that
take who would fight you there Facebook
and YouTube oh and they would [ __ ] go
to war yeah
they would go to war hardcore remember
Google made sixty eight billion dollars
we had revenue last year what did
Facebook me
probably some like 20 yeah I probably
have yeah that's a lot yeah you know
where you know they're gonna fight you
so you know changing this it means
changing habits and changing and
changing perception and changing habits
I mean habits the the thing that I think
people when I hear really savvy
entrepreneurs talk the thing that a lot
of them say is we this is the habit
we're trying to change yeah because if
you can change a habit and or create a
have it yeah right
that's a mean yeah that's the that's the
real thing you have to get that you have
to boil down if you want to sell an
actual practical life benefiting product
so Facebook gonna change the user gonna
change their habits cuz if the user
doesn't change their habits
why would Facebook change so is it more
beneficial than it is a con on people
though you know just be a little too
it's too it's almost too easy of an
answer because I feel like there's a
percentage of users who are able to do
that effectively but you're inevitably
gonna have a big percentage of people
who are like yo I I'm I can't deal with
changing my internet browsing habits
right now because you know I'm going to
work I'm failing for my family and when
I hop on the computer here it's like I'm
not gonna jump on the lace latest like
hashtag trend whatever and and just like
I don't want to deal with that right you
know know the how to create to change
that habit I mean that that's that's my
point
you know that's why I don't think
Facebook will change I don't think
YouTube will change yeah I mean YouTube
they're workers that YouTube great
people great people at Facebook right so
when you complain I hear it you know or
you know when other influencers or other
youtubers complain or partners with me
like that I hear it and I go talk to
youtube there are people were there to
care that someone lost you know I mean
there are there are content creators I
know that lost millions if not 50 to 100
million views this year based on an
algorithm change but they can't explain
to me what that algorithm change was or
how it affected that person right
because they aren't because the person
Emily is dining with doesn't understand
the program and sometimes the
programmers don't even understand they
make tiny changes I mean I was talking
to I was
to an engineer I won't say at which one
of those two sites but he made he made a
change that literally moved an icon
eight pixels from one side to the other
and it in and apparently it affected
millions of views millions of views so
imagine me that contra crater just lost
50 million views
you know because and which is you know a
really significant CPM what really
amount of money right like you're pissed
but the same time you're really just
kind of a drop in the bucket to a
company that gets two billion views a
day or two billion views a minute or
whatever they're at right now right it's
insane
so they you know they it's tough how are
you gonna change that Wow
well I mean I mean I have theories you
have theories yeah well I'd love to hear
that because I think so let's I'm just
trying to wrap my head around this to a
little bit but ultimately you know I
think it's this is I think this is
really important because everyone I mean
listening to this and most people now
are watching stuff online digitally
YouTube Facebook whatever wherever your
sources doesn't matter Instagram
Instagram you got disagree I'm lovin
scream out and the thing is is that yeah
like I was talking about this is like an
ad based economy now and so you have
content that is created to fit within
that ad based economy so now it's you
know Google and Facebook they're shaping
the actual type of content people get
you know it's not just like on it's not
like this is the clear unadulterated
message this is this is everything that
goes up onto YouTube right now is a
creator jumping through whatever hoops
and hurdles and going navigating through
whatever constraints they need to to
make a product that is ingested by these
I mean II that's a good thing by the
Machine and then it finally gets to the
creator so to speak and we've seen go I
mean just in the type of content you see
on YouTube over the last few years as
you know as the more as YouTube becomes
more of a system we've seen that that
shift so yeah there it's tangible it's
tangible I mean I mean just look at your
suggests
stuff yeah okay I'll get suggested stuff
from you know the NFL or EA you know or
you know one or the other but it
encourages people not to have not to
create content that's predatory at least
in part I mean it doesn't solve every
gate so it doesn't fix the entire game
to perfect but it I think it it
eliminates people from being like I'm
just gonna go on about things unchecked
unchecked and I hope to monetize it and
make money off of it so what do you
think Luke then what's the what's that
other version what other what are your
other solutions your what's your
theories theory
I mean without being too specific I mean
there needs to be you know a movement
where the creators and the consumer you
know what's funny is it kind of happens
organically right I mean if you guys you
know you look at the struggle that
content creators are going through right
now and and the change in the CPM and
the change in the algorithm and all
these different things content creators
are now like okay I gotta think of a
different revenue source I bet I think
of something else more steady I've got
to think about you know XY and Z and
what has come out of that right our
platforms like patreon you know you know
in YouTube and in twitch and you got the
button that we call the subscribe yeah
these different members days on YouTube
yeah what both platforms hilarious is I
started I hurt me started hearing side
tangent real quick I heard a alternative
monetization shrunk down to alt line
right this is opening your guitar case
[Laughter]
use of this term alt mon by one of the
platforms in December of 2017 I kind of
laughed and I texted my business partner
and I was like hey you know so-and-so
wants us to know the future is alt mine
and I was I was like okay duh but also
like this this is hilarious that this
company shortened this thing because
they're famous for shortening things and
I swear to you within three months all
three or four platforms that we were
talking to we're using the same
mónica they all went from saying the
full term I'll turn in my ization to
Altamont
our focus is on all mods we're gonna
we're gonna create the best user
experience for all months okay great
what do you mean by that
you know what I mean so it's happening
naturally and it's happening organically
I think there needs to be you know a
concerted movement you know if I'm being
completely flat and honest you know
you'll be hearing me talk about flipping
the funnel next year you know changing
changing the direction in which you not
only consume content and share content
but also in which the you know the the
advertising where the advertising
dollars go in right and in my mind you
know you guys are already part of that
flip it's starting to happen and it's
beginning the platform's have started
the content creators have started doing
it on our own out of necessity of break
that down for a non youtuber well the
infrastructure that was built on you
know a massive capitalist economy that
you know that has production
distribution and will call entertainment
slash dissemination of information as
three pillars you know your three
pillars of you know the economy if you
will all those are in flux in the
adamant or the add ads babies buyers and
yeah there you go and creators and
consumers yeah all focused at the
consumer right right and that funnel
like that infrastructure was built on on
that structure right it's still in
existence yeah and you're talking about
earlier the you know the funnel the
advertising funnel is still a wide
funnel that funnels down through a small
group of agencies and distributors right
and yeah technically the funnel is
getting smaller because know the duopoly
we just got our I see right and then
it's then it's dispersed out cash comes
in here it's this funnel and goes out
right right so and it disperses itself
across those different companies and
different creators and NextEra cetera
the future in my mind would be to flip
that and create a layer between the
consumer and the advertiser
right okay and that was a bit well I
mean you still have a list oh he's still
the pool of people's subscribers or what
we'll see it'll see how it comes out
right but flip the funnel I'm gonna keep
saying that right next you're gonna hear
it a lot well it seems like enemy I
don't think you're gonna flip 68th bill
in and no not at all
yeah but I don't mean like a piece that
maybe it's Altamont maybe okay I forgot
that I was wearing saw your house today
I looked up at the screens like oh yeah
yeah I think it's one of the best secret
restaurants in LA not secret I mean it's
I look like one of their employees right
now because I bought one of them please
see sure it's oh I thought it was just
like we don't actually just brought in a
guy from sake house really adapt about
advertisement in the 21st century no
sorry I just looked up the screens like
oh yeah I didn't dress this cash today
guys apologies that's fine so so what's
all this stuff about the Industrial
Revolution that you're talking about
yeah what what happens there man that
first name but you mentioned that yeah
sure I mean I think I think I think the
most powerful revolution you know is not
the American right you know I'm gonna
sound blasphemous I guess I don't think
I'm the only person who thinks it's not
the American Revolution and it wasn't
the French Revolution and you know
whatever
I think the industrial evolution has
shaped our you know modern society more
than any other revolution yeah hands
down hey no yeah I think you get
pushback on something you know fate some
people if you study the history that
came about after that just you're not
comparison I'm assuming you're not
talking about like steam engines
yeah with the infrastructure that that
disrupted no that was the first one I'm
talking about was that was the I was
both the building of the infrastructure
of a global economy steam steel steam
steel yeah let's just think about what
happened in that period
mm-hm and you know we're talking about a
period between let's call it and I think
again we
they have people disagree with this year
1832 1920s okay yeah in that time the
modes of district distribution and the
modes of transportation totally changed
right yeah you once had you know if you
wanted to have ended slavery
it ended slavery but it maybe you did a
lot of different things right a lot of
difference but like you could create a
product all of a sudden New York shipped
to San Francisco or shipping Paris yeah
you know and it still be you know it'd
be relatively quickly
yeah because of the steam engine and all
these different things yeah rail and no
you don't need sales on your boat
anymore so yeah the modes of
distribution modes of transportation
totally upended and changed right
products are cheaper products lost lots
of production the the the
interchangeable part yeah wasn't created
it I don't think it's like the 1840s now
I'll think about that prior to the 1840s
everything you hadn't made your knife
your gun your hoe your clothes
everything was unique and individual
period the intangible part right and in
the end up with the industrial with the
production that change within days you
know interchangeable party creating an
assembly line production you know mass
production right unable to create many
things that are exactly the same product
1,000 think firearms might have been
they've been fundamental in starting
that well the firearms were fundamental
in in creating the interchangeable part
right that's not in creating yeah yeah
in the entertainment that's funny that's
that's something I've never actually
considered like oh yeah it's just like a
nut that fits two different screws made
by two different companies right didn't
exist until I you know I could buy this
pen your pen almost the exact same thing
changed out you big well I can't tell
the difference you know what I mean yeah
there's a point in time where you'd be
like oh this one has slightly different
flecks of gray yeah whatever yeah yeah
so it loses a luster if you will some
people would say but it also creates
economies of scale and it changes it
what you can make and it changes how you
view consumption because now all of a
sudden the cost of a good goes way down
right yeah I can produce thousands of
them instead of it being an individual
craftsman making me one thing the cost
of goods go way down you know again
we're talking about the building of a
middle-class ball what the descent the
now the third thing in flux at this
point is the dissemination of
information okay prior to the Industrial
Revolution I want us and I'm getting at
my numbers wrong anyway you know but I
want to say less than 50% of the
populace was literate yeah right and the
printing press the radio the Telegraph
all this different things it changed so
much the the how humans were able to
consume information yeah all the sudden
like if winkin was shot you know 20
years before 30 years before it would
have taken months for California to his
yeah weeks at leas yeah weeks yeah at
least all right instead it was like
right not like not like it is today but
it was like whoa yeah I found out the
next day right and I live in Indiana
whoa how did that you know what I mean
like all of a sudden information it
really compresses the time and space in
which you know information can be shared
and blah blah blah
now so now all of a sudden we have
what's being built out over those the
industrial evolution is uh you know a
robust massive you know economy that's
based on consumerism right and if you're
gonna have consumerism and you're gonna
have people making different types of
products guess what and we got
advertising we're gonna get people where
the of your product you got to get them
buying your body you got all this stuff
so all of a sudden the infrastructure of
the ad world starts being built you know
uh print you know which is still
amazingly a shockingly large portion of
our ad buy every year I think it's still
like seventeen percent print paper right
well people advertising print still
seventeen percent that's nuts
increase but I digress I mean the point
is you know all that infrastructure is
being built out right still I mean in
just like in products and and all these
different things there
still owned by very few mountain people
you know the money going to the top and
that's the first hurts Carnegie
Rockefeller all these different you know
we called them great man and you know of
the Industrial Age yeah becoming super
uber wealthy and not being part of
quote-unquote the ruling class you know
prior to this period you know didn't
exist yeah for you to be like massively
powerful I mean they're it's not that's
not Harvard century I mean there's large
families that were built there you know
stuff one trade but yeah usually had
somebody in the ruling class hundreds of
years ruling class family yeah so now
you have you know people again people
who built themselves up you know and you
have the built you know the the
foundation of the American Dream is
based in is embedded in the Industrial
Revolution absolutely all these
different things that are built on top
of this massive commerce society and the
advertising industry being built same
way you know and again that's why I use
the term of a funnel there's a huge
amount cashing and we talk about ads you
know there's people who buy the ads and
then they hire ad agencies that just you
know that come up with a creative that
then distribute the ads on that just you
know and the platforms okay and the
reason this is all influx and in change
is because this is a cell phone and this
is one of the strongest computers in the
world you know 20 years ago and now it's
in that bucket right and now I can
deliver I can watch full movies you can
play video games I can do everything on
this thing right so now the ads are
probably all going can buy and sell ads
on I in so answer so you know the
disruption that's happening the
disruption that has been happening over
the last 15 years with technology and if
you look at the music industry all these
disruption is has to do with the access
of that content right it has to do with
what it costs for you to get that access
right and that class used to be you have
to sit here and watch five 30-second ads
period right you don't watch a show
you're gonna have to sit here and watch
five thirty second is no longer the
truth so when I say what Google did in
2006 being one of the most disruptive
and most important decisions of the last
hundred years when it comes to the
industry what I'm saying is
they genuinely this is where I think
Facebook totally misses the mark
you know they genuinely created a
partnership program where a percentage
of the ad revenue goes to you the
content creator you the producer of that
stuff they they in a way in a weird way
that both widened and shrunk the filter
they white on the filter because they
made millions of other people who could
be distributors they shrunk it in that
instead of buying from like ten
different people you have to buy from
one source that's Google right so and I
mean that's what's you know really
fascinating about time we're living in
you know my company through black dot
your guys company court-ordered both
relatively new young companies that are
incredibly successful you know someone
wanted to acquire us somebody would want
to inquire you if you would acquire you
if you want to do right but what's
amazing is you get to do that on your
own you could decide that so you know
back to the Industrial Revolution you
know why I think that this is an in a
way a new industrial revolution you know
twenty years ago
guys want to make movies and shorts and
TV you've literally had what two avenues
yeah I mean yeah yeah hit toe line in
the [ __ ] slow get out that's why you
get all these crazy Hollywood stories
about people doing heinous [ __ ] because
they're like the power the power is so
skewed well I I think you know I'm just
trying to like as I listen I I I keep
trying to simplify it and like distill
this and it sounds kind of like when you
talk about the Industrial Revolution
compared to 2006 here all we're really
talking about is it's it's about the the
reach so to speak you know the
Industrial Revolution creates like a
physical tangible reach to more people
in a mental reach and that what happens
in 2006 is through the creation of
content creators or influencers you know
you're basically handing over the keys
to more people for that kind of reach
now you know let me back up no cuz I
don't think I explains also so no I I
actually think I think all those all
those things are in flux again right the
modes of production right so the modes
of production you know from a cost
perspective you know just one let's go
20 years
hundred years ago let's go 20 years ago
yeah incredibly expensive for you to
start up right let's not even go to
distribution like distribution getting
something filmed and made and seen
literally it took a lightning bolt if
you if you self financed it and you
didn't go through the Hollywood way it
took a lightning bolt one of them
billion chance for your [ __ ] to be seen
right and it was incredibly expensive to
make
right so the cost of production again
has gone down so much that you can do
this right the modes of distribution the
most difficult part of this whole
ecosystem is the modes of distribution
yeah it's no longer the most difficult
part and I'll get to that in a second
but the most difficult part in the
industrialization was the modes of
distribution because it was also the
most expensive part you had to build the
railroad you you know you had to pay
someone to do all these get your product
from here to here mm-hmm right or to get
seen you know back in the day when there
only two V TV channels you only two
people you could go to get something
distributed I mean like it was the
hardest part of the chain yeah right it
is now flip it it's now the easiest yeah
the hardest and most expensive is now
the easiest but now you have places like
Amazon Etsy ups ups I mean just pick
pick a because delivery service yeah I
mean she I could use [ __ ] uber to do
it you know what I mean my modes a
distribution have changed so much and is
so much more accessible than ever before
so no all three things that we were
talking about have changed in an influx
production cheaper more accessible
we're doable if you guys want to do you
can make your own merch t-shirts right
here yeah fairly cheap you know you can
cover your car you know cover your class
you can make probably make better
margins it's difficult yeah it takes a
lot of you know your Volvo you could do
it the sales infrastructure online is
the biggest hurdle to that one correct
yeah Wow
for us it was yeah yeah so now you've
loads of pressing have changed become
more easier to do produce things yeah
again whether you know again it could be
a t-shirt it could be a
you know could be a table yeah you know
it can be whatever it is you could sell
it on Etsy there's different platforms
you can sell it on right so distribution
is totally changed what Amazon is doing
the distribution is totally crazy right
so distribution is 100% James production
interchange the dissemination of
information there's no argument there
you know the entertainment and the
dissemination of dissemination of
information is crazy
different now yeah the modes of
distribution they're you know if you
look at iTunes you do them you know
Facebook Twitter Instagram whatever I
mean they're free portals in which you
pay a license fee prior that I had to
have I had to give them I mean I had to
create a great product that you know
then I would sell 30% or 50% of my
revenue to immediately without even
seeing anything I probably had to do
other things for them and I'll you know
I mean like it was it was incredibly
hard to get your [ __ ] seen and now it's
free the difference though you know is
unlike Industrial Revolution you have an
infant shelf space no so you have you
know there's no limit to shelf so what
you guys have done you know creating
audience building audience through great
content authentic content you know
strong brand voice you created the most
difficult part you've changed the most
of what part of the past is is no longer
distribution right it is now the
dissemination of information the sale
you know getting to the community to the
audience because there's so many
different platforms and you're being hit
with so no I do believe the analogy
stands up it's not just adds that has
changed in in in today's paradigm it may
not be the as great a shift as the
Industrial Revolution but it's truly a
shift of prong across all the major
parts of production all the major parts
of our economy yeah and I think that's
why you know again I always see that
thing on Facebook or Twitter I mean well
it's like top 10 companies of 2003
you know Google's not even in it
apples at the bottom yeah you know I
mean top ten companies of 2018 mm-hm
Google Facebook Amazon you know there's
a term for it an investment now then
yeah the four horsemen no there's like a
Google Apple Facebook Netflix there's oh
yeah yeah I've heard that's it I don't
care but that I mean that I mean that's
why I think it's a apt an apt analogy
cuz I do believe it's not the same
change cuz you know you know the
Industrial Revolution only happens once
but I do believe all those things have
been in flux we're getting to a place
where you know again it's codifying and
that's I mean I think that's probably
what's frustrating for new creators yeah
in your community it is harder to get
seen today than it was in 2009 2010 when
you guys were building the audience yeah
well I mean that yeah that's what I was
that's why he's bringing up this the
idea of it's kind of like the keys so to
speak you know and they were the first
set of keys was created in the
Industrial Revolution when and then
these keys let you access people in both
like tangible and intangible means
whether through communication or product
you know and over the twentieth century
we see that getting refined and refined
but now it's like we were kind of
starting to hit the bottom floor now
where everyone has those keys now it's
just that the value of them is dropped
because everyone has them now and that's
kind of what you're talking about when
it yeah when it says when we talk about
a creator who just starts out in 2018
yeah or in 2020 because now with
everyone having that access or that
level of communication it becomes you
know exponentially more difficult yeah
do you think that then ad dollars will
effectively sort out like who the like
who the legitimate creators are is that
where were is that the space that we're
in now how does that work cuz like if
they're you know this is the fine line
that that Google and Facebook are trying
to thread right now there I don't know
that's tough yeah it's tough because I
mean I think I tried to make some point
earlier when I mean what YouTube is
as they've you know they spent a lot of
2014-2015 really building up partners
like PlayStation and yeh and you know
beauty probably some beauty products
whatever you know helping them build you
know they spent a part of the one
hundred nine dollars right there initial
whatever help build those brands up so
now you have brand endemic pages and now
I'm getting those in suggestions I would
never [ __ ] watch a dummy in
Activision video yeah yeah and give me
give me syndicates video about activism
or mini lads you know what I mean or
whoever's video that's talking about the
announcement I'd rather see their
opinion on the announcement and actual
one but they're giving me the actual one
right you own I mean yeah because the
actual one comes with that dollars right
so it's it's this weird thing i i i i
mean listen it's you know to to say that
[Music]
it'll be a meritocracy moving forward
would be a lie I know you know but to
say that it's completely gone
I think is also missing the mark I think
there's I genuinely believe there's
still obvious you know room for growth
and opportunity for people to build
audiences I just think it has to be done
differently than it was used to be yeah
you know our keys back in the day which
are still in keys you know consistency
and quality and was the other one
consistent quality in community you know
yeah I think was kind of the three keys
you had in the early internet yeah
social days you know if you stop if you
stop posting for a few months you were
probably dead yeah yeah I mean the
internet forgets about you they move on
to the next grader she had to be
consistent you had to be qualities you
had to make content that people would
come back for him you had to build
community had to actually interact with
them so I think those are still true
yeah but there's other things that have
to happen to what are those things
I don't know I mean try to figure that
out I think it's still true as watch
this from you guys videos before I came
in
just to like you know hey they miss
anything and I think it's still true
today and I used to say this to creators
you know and no.9 2010-2011 get really
good hitting signals you know
and try to hit a home run four times a
year yeah you know what I mean like get
really good at making good consistent
content you know whatever and four times
a year you know whether it's an event
it's coming up it's a Call of Duty draw
up or I don't know what it is you know
really put a creative effort into trying
to hit a home run
all right so that you have the community
to give you the boost that the other
community can come and grab you I still
think that's true you know I still think
that's true be really good at
consistency and hitting good singles and
when you hit a home run be willing to
optimize I mean your guys is spider-man
video for example I think you know if
you look at all your videos they're
doing great you know you're averaging
what three four hundred thousand views
sometimes five yeah but that one hit
four mil yeah that's home run I mean
back in the day your homeland's were
like 20 mil right those days are
probably gone well we still have a few
of those like so yeah but it's more of
the fact that international audiences
are like are certain to open up a little
more that's more why so they're getting
circulated in other there on a few there
they're like a few years behind where we
are here when it comes to that side of
virality but yeah so yeah I don't know
if I can answer what that magic sauce is
right now may I think it is evolving I
mean just you know like I said I still
think the ad dollars are evolving but
like you guys said you gotta find those
ultimately it's really that is the
business side of yeah being creative
yeah and you know YouTube and Facebook
have taken a lot of that effort and work
away from the average creator as far as
like how do I build what I do into a
business because they handle that think
you know it's like oh you're telling me
I just got a hit record and hit upload
and oh you'll send the checks and they
like yep we got it and and so again
distributions change dude Altman though
but Altamont is that is that is kind of
like alright well how do we do let's
let's imagine YouTube isn't in the
picture somehow yeah how how do we go
about our lives well we're still making
videos yeah you guys are killing it
we're fun fun to make yeah I think it'll
be again it would be a really
interesting a couple years I think
things need to change
I think things on Facebook gotta change
yeah yeah you know and I think I mean if
anyone from Facebook's listening I keep
telling you guys in meetings and I know
you guys have been talking about it
create a partnership program you know
and not a it doesn't have to be crazy
this whole bunk with the onboarding for
cash thing give me a break
it's so annoying I mean it's it just
turns the creator community off yeah and
you'll get a couple people who get make
a little cash and whatever but you you
know you really want to be more
long-term thinking them for those this
thing who don't know what this is
basically I'm gonna talk completely
openly about this Facebook
offered money in exchange for uploads
hard cash dollars amounts in exchange
for hard numbers of uploads as a way to
get creators onto their platform but
didn't offer any terms for the future
didn't offer any terms for how they're
gonna create creator community didn't
offer any terms for how they're going to
reward us for staying on the platform
just simply offered that in exchange of
a hope that people would onboard yeah on
to Facebook do it Facebook do it
twitching you to do it dance the most
[ __ ] like thing I've heard yeah great
yeah I don't understand why you can't do
that I don't know I and and I got it I
got it I got an excuse once that was
tech based like our ecosystem doesn't
work like theirs and tracking your views
and we can't do XY and Z and I was like
really you can't you can't do it Twitter
website exactly how you wanted it you
can't do it YouTube does like that are
you that what you're saying you just you
just can't build the tech like I don't
believe that yeah yeah it's it's it's
pretty strange but I mean it kind of
makes sense though to because I don't
think it's used in a different way I
don't think people like it's it's not
it's not a community in the way that
YouTube is Facebook is for like the
people in your immediate life and that's
why I'm so effective in election right
yeah yeah so it's like you but you
wouldn't go there to go hey I wonder
what
the corridor digital boys are up do you
know it's like it's absolutely not well
they created a better experience yeah if
they they would but that's that's kind
of almost in a way an overhaul the
system it's like a second version of
Facebook where you that's what they're
doing with Instagram that's why they're
doing Instagram yeah yeah well I'll see
how that works I guess yeah well I hate
to say but I think we're done our time I
think that was fascinating it was a that
was a really really cool little barely
even like there's so many more things
like yeah I know with that well it's
funny I mean I think we got into our
origin stories a bit I mean I I find how
we became friends and like remain
friends like really awesome
yeah like we have a new hopefully a new
project coming up together and it
generally wasn't like I wasn't thinking
like oh I want to you know work a
quarter cuz X Y and D it was like like
you know my business partner was like
hey think of a group people he'd want to
work with yeah and then I was like oh
that's a good idea you know what I mean
I obviously thought Tom and Craig and
then I was driving home and I
immediately like oh [ __ ] honey I love
work on this guy's have you Brad to work
with them I merely called Jake was like
hey I bought an idea out there yeah and
I think that's where we're getting in
our careers and that's what makes you
know what you guys do what I do so fun
is it's like oh we get a we get to
decide moving forward who and what we
work on right yeah and that has to do
with the Internet and that's where that
integrity comes in baby
it really dude it really is here's my
cheat yo near my cheesiest sales line
yes yeah here's my cheesiest sales line
and I use it all the time my whole team
uses it when talking to brands and
trying to get them to buy money with us
you know I said hey you can't take the
you out of youtube so don't try let us
work with you on the brand messaging you
know and then we'll work with the
content creators and we'll come up with
something better because like you just
giving us a script is gonna just aren't
authentic it's gonna bomb please don't
do this I know you want to spend tons of
money I get that you have cash but
with us you know because you can't take
that you out alright it's true though
it is that's 100% true right it's it's a
salesy pitch yeah it is it's cheesy when
I say it a little piece of my soul is
like you saying but what you're saying
is 100% wrong
yeah well I mean it's just I've said it
a billion times I can imagine you know
you can't take two you know you did so
don't try so yeah I used that one that
was actually like my only my second
meeting at YouTube ever when I use that
one yeah and then like six months year
later like I heard one of their exactly
use it I was like well thanks for coming
on and uh hopefully we can do this again
but yeah yeah yeah thank you
yeah that's great guys guys thanks for
listening to the podcast and as always
if you enjoyed it head on over to
corridor digital dot store and get some
merchandise to support more episodes
subscribe on youtube subscribe on Apple
podcasts Google podcasts Spotify podcast
doesn't matter where you hit subscribe
but thanks for listening
we appreciate you see ya out there see
ya out there on the on the frontier